PROFESSOR: Having looked at the
quizzes in a preliminary
fashion, I come to the
conclusion that some notes on
tensors would be useful for
the remainder of the term.
So at great pain and personal
sacrifice I will endeavor to
[INAUDIBLE]
All right, let me remind you of
where we were a week ago--
before a slight unpleasantness
intervened--
and we had just begun to look
at the properties of a very
useful surface, the
representation quadric.
And we said that to define it we
would take the elements of
a second rank tensor, something
of the form A11,
A12, A13, A21, A22, A23,
A31, A32, A33.
And we'd use those elements as
coefficients in a second rank,
a quadratic equation, of the
form Aij Xi Xj equals 1.
OK, so the Xi and Xj are
the coordinates in our
three-dimensional space.
And the set of coordinates that
satisfy this equation--
setting the right hand side
equal to a constant--
will define some surface
in space.
And it's going to be a surface
that is a quadratic form, so
it is going to be one of four
different surfaces that can be
defined by such an equation.
One would be an ellipsoid, and
in general this would be an
ellipsoid oriented in an
arbitrary fashion with respect
to the reference axes.
And it would have a general
shape, so the three principle
axes of the ellipsoid would
be of different lengths.
Then we saw we could also get
a hyperboloid of one sheet.
One sheet means one surface--
continuous surface.
This was the surface that had
an hourglass like shape that
pinched down in the middle,
and the cross-section, in
general, would be
an ellipsoid.
And the asymptotes to this
surface would define a
boundary between directions in
which the radius was real,
which meant a positive value
of the property, and a
direction in which the radius
was imaginary, even though
that may boggle the mind.
And if you take an imaginary
quantity and square it, you're
going to get a negative
number.
So this surface would describe
a property that was positive
in some directions and negative
in magnitude over
another range of directions.
Then the third surface was a
hyperboloid of two sheets.
And this was a surface that
looked like two [INAUDIBLE]
with an elliptical cross-section
that were nose
to nose, but not touching
the origin.
And in this range of directions
between the
asymptote to those two lobes the
radius was imaginary, the
property negative and then
there were a range of
directions that would intersect
the surface of
either of these two sheets in
there in those directions the
property would be positive.
Then the fourth one--
which is encountered only
rarely, but as we pointed out
does exist in the
case of thermal
expansion as a property--
and this would be an imaginary
ellipsoid.
This would be an ellipsoid in
which the distance from the
origin out to the surface was
everywhere imaginary.
And this would be a property
then that was negative in all
directions in space.
And that doesn't seem to be a
physically realizable thing,
we pointed out that for the
linear thermal expansion
coefficient there are a small
number of very unusual
materials that when you heat
them up contract uniformly in
all directions.
Very remarkable property, but
that does indeed, thankfully,
provide me with an example of an
imaginary ellipsoid quadric
that does represent, indeed, a
realizable physical property.
OK, this surface, we said,
had two rather remarkable
properties.
The first property was that if
we looked at the radius from
the origin out to the surface of
the quadric, a property of
the quadric is that the radius
out in some direction--
that would be defined
in terms of the
three direction cosines--
the radius has the property that
it is given by 1 over the
square root of the value of the
property in that direction.
Or, alternatively, the value
of the property in the
direction is 1 over
the magnitude
of the radius squared.
OK, so this is what gives us the
meaning of the imaginary
radii, the imaginary radii 1
squared would give you a
negative property.
But again, I point out, it's
obvious here-- but we have to
keep it in mind--
that the value of the property
and the magnitude of the
radius are related in a
reciprocal fashion, not only
reciprocal, but reciprocal
of the square.
So if this is the quadric A, a
polar quad of the value of the
property A as a function of
direction would have its
maximum value along the minimum
principal axis and,
correspondingly, the minimum
value of the property along
the maximum radius
of the quadric.
So that is sort of
counter-intuitive, you think
big radius, big value of the
property, no, goes not only as
the reciprocal, but as the
reciprocal of the square.
So the value of the property
with direction is not a
quadratic form any longer,
it's based on a quadratic
equation, but when you
square the radius
it's no longer quadratic.
Looks as though we have the
value of the property as a
function of direction, but looks
as though we've lost
information about
the direction of
the resulting vector.
The direction that we're talking
about is always the
direction in which we're
applying the generalized
force, the electric field, or
the temperature gradient, or
the magnetic field.
But the direction of the thing
that happens is defined by the
basic equation that gives
us the tensor.
But as I demonstrated with you
last time, that information is
in the quadric also, and
this is the so-called
radius-normal property.
Which doesn't involve exactly
what it sounds like, but what
it tells us to do is a way of
determining the direction of
what happens is to go out in a
particular direction, along
some radius that will intersect
the surface of the
quadric at some point.
And then at the point where
the directional vector
emerges, construct a vector that
is normal to the surface.
And so if this then were the
direction of an applied
electric field, the
direction to the--
normal to the surface of the
quadric where that direction
intersected--
the surface of the
representation quadric--
this would be in the case of
conductivity the direction in
which the current flows.
So everything that you care to
know about the anisotropy of
the property that's described
by a given tensor, and about
the direction of
what happens--
the generalized displacement
as you apply a vector--
is contained within
the quadric.
But one caveat, this
holds only if
the tensor is symmetric.
And I think this is where we
finished up just before the
quiz, only if Aij equals Aji
does the radius-normal
property work.
OK, any comments or
questions on this?
OK, let me now turn to a
practical question of
interpretation.
If you were indeed to measure
a physical property as a
function of direction, and you
get a tensor that is a general
tensor, A11, A12, A13.
A21, A22, A23.
A31, A32, A33.
All the numbers are non-zero.
You know that the diagonal
values in the tensor are going
to give you the value of
the property along X1.
Or, in general, the diagonal
terms give you the value of
the property along Xi.
Aii gives you the property
along Xi.
You have not the foggiest idea,
if the quadric has a
general orientation, what the
maximum and minimum values of
the property might be, and
these might concern you.
Given the tensor that you've
determined, what are the
largest values, what is the
largest value of the property,
what is the smallest value
of the property?
And if the crystal has any
symmetry these directions
might be the direction of
symmetry axes in the crystal.
So for many reasons you might
want to know the maximum and
minimum value of the property.
And then for some applications
for a real chunk of crystal
that you've examined relative
to an arbitrary set of axes,
you might want to ask how should
I orient that crystal
so that I can cut a rod from
it that has, let's say, the
maximum or minimum thermal
conductivity.
If you're using a piece of
ceramic let's say, as a probe
into a furnace, you wouldn't
want that probe to conduct
much heat, so you'd like the
minimum thermal expansion
coefficient, for example.
If you were making a window out
of a transparent single
crystal, it'd be a very small
window, but you might want the
smallest thermal conductivity
normal to the surface, and
therefore you might want to
make your single crystal
window oriented in a particular
direction.
So I hope I've convinced you
with enough straw questions
that we can knock down easily
that, yes, this would be an
interesting thing to know.
So how can we do this?
Let me show you some simple
geometry that let's us set up
an equation for finding these
directions right away.
And it'll be based on the
following observation, that
when the direction of, let's
say, the applied electric
field is a long one of the
principal axes, then and only
then is the direction of the
generalized displacement
exactly parallel to
the radius vector.
We go off in any other direction
other than a
principal axis, the generalized
displacement is
not parallel to the radius
vector out to the surface of
the quadric.
We look at the equation of the
property A11 X1 plus A12 X2
plus A13 X3.
This is the X1 component of the
generalized displacement.
Similarly, A21 X1 plus A22 X2
plus A23 X3 is going to be the
X2 component.
And A31 X1 plus A32 X2 plus
A33 times X3, guess what?
That's going to be the X3
component of the displacement.
Now we said that these X's give
us the direction of the
displacement as we let the
coordinates of that point X1,
X2, X3 roam around the surface
of the quadric.
When we land at a point on the
surface of the quadric which
is where a principal axis
emerges, then, and only then,
is the resulting
vector parallel
to the applied vector.
And this means each component of
the resulting vector has to
be proportional to a vector
out to the point at that
location, X1, X2, X3.
So what I'm saying then is
that when we are on a
principal axis the X1 component
of what happens is
going to be proportional
to X1.
And the X2 component of the
vector that happens has to be
proportional to X2, and this
is the radial vector out to
that point.
And, similarly, the X3 component
of what happens has
to be parallel to the coordinate
X3, the vector out
to the surface of the
quadric along X3.
So let me make this an equation,
now, by putting in a
constant for the unknown
proportionality constant.
And what I'll do, just for
arbitrary reasons, is call
that proportionality constant
"lambda." So this, then, is a
set of equations that will give
me, if I solve for X1,
X2, and X3, the coordinates of
one of the three points that
sit out on the surface of the
quadric at the location where
a principal axis emerges.
So let me rearrange these
equations to a
form that I can solve.
And I'll make the equations
homogeneous by bringing lambda
X1 over to the left hand side
of the equation, and let me
point out that this
is the same lambda
in all three equations.
There's a proportionality
constant between the radial
vector out to the surface of the
quadric and each component
of the vector that results.
So my set of equations will be
A11 minus lambda X1 plus A12
times X2 plus A13 times X3, and
that's now equal to zero
on the right.
Next equation would
be A21 X1--
and notice I'm not combining A12
and A21 into numerically
the same constant, representing
it by the same
quantity, I'm just leaving
them be separate and
independent at this point.
And then the middle term here
is A22 minus lambda times X2
plus A23 times X3 equals 0.
And the third equation, you can
anticipate how that turns
out, it's A31 X1 plus A32
times X2 plus A33 minus
lambda, and that's
equal to zero.
So this, then, is a set of
linear equations and they're
called homogeneous equations.
And that has solved our problem
for us, all we have to
do is solve for X1, X2, X3.
Except that if the nine
coefficients Aij are all
arbitrary and lambda is a
constant this set of equations
has only one solution, and that
solution is X1 equals X2
equals X3 equals 0, and that
indeed will wipe out every one
of these lines.
And that is not a very
interesting solution.
The only case in which this is
not the only solution is that
if the condition that the
determinant of the
coefficients is equal to zero,
then we can find a real set of
X1, X2, X3.
So the condition that a solution
exists is that A11
minus lambda A12 A13, and A21
A22 minus lambda A23, A31 A32
A33 minus lambda, this
determinant has
to be equal to zero.
All right, so we know how to
expand the determinant, we'll
do a little number crunching,
and I'm not going to write it
down explicitly, but we'll have
a term A11 minus lambda
and this will be among other
terms in the expansion A22
minus lambda A23 A32 A33 minus
lambda and then there'll be
another determinant that
involves this term A12 plus
its cofactor plus A13
times its cofactor.
Unfortunately none of these
terms are zero in general, so
I'm going to have three
terms here.
If I expand this term, I'm going
to get something in A11
minus lambda A22 minus lambda
times A33 minus lambda and a
bunch of other terms that I
won't bother to write down
explicitly.
The only point I want to draw at
this particular juncture is
to note that this is a
third rank equation.
In lambda.
It's a cubic equation.
And what this means
is that there are
going to be three roots.
And lets call them lambda 1,
lambda 2, and lambda 3.
And that's the way
it should be.
There are three principle axes,
so we should have three
values of the constant lambda
that we could put into this
equation that will let us
solve explicitly for the
coordinates X1, X2, and X3,
which sits on the surface of
the quadric where our principal
axis pokes out.
Three different principal axes,
so this should be three
solutions to the third
rank equation that
we've defined here.
OK I think you've all seen this
sort of problem before.
The lambdas are called
characteristic values.
Or, on the basis that things
sound more impressive in
German, these are called
the eigenvalues,
meaning the same thing.
So using nothing more than the
properties of the quadric and
some linear algebra we have
stumbled headlong into an
eigenvalue problem, which
is a well known sort of
mathematical problem associated
with a large number
of physical situations and
a lot to do with physical
properties in particular.
OK, now I have a question
for you.
How we going to solve
this silly thing?
I know--
well the answer is I poke it
into my laptop, and out comes
the answer.
But that's not satisfying, we
should know how to do this if
our batteries were dead and we
needed the answer in a hurry.
Well, I know how to solve
a second rank question.
If I have equation of the form
ax squared plus bx plus c
equals 0, I know the
solution to that.
It's etched indelibly in my
memory and it says that x
equals minus b plus or minus the
square root of b squared
minus 4ac all over 2a.
Impressed you, didn't I?
You know why I remember that?
I learned high school algebra
from a throwback--
a teacher who was a throwback
to the Elizabethan period.
You know how when people go to
a remote island they suddenly
find an example of
a species that
everyone thought was extinct?
Well, to secondary education
[? Ms. Dourier ?]
was a species that had long gone
extinct, but happened to
be preserved at the high
school that I attended.
[? Ms. Dourier ?]
was a very tall woman, ramrod
straight, with a pile of snow
white hair on the
top of her head.
She invariably dressed in a
long, black skirt, and a white
blouse that had puffy sleeves,
and a collar with frilly
things on the top, and,
invariably, a black ribbon
around the frilly
lace collar top.
Her mode of enlightened
education was to have all of
the students in the class have
a notebook that was open.
And one hapless member of the
class was called upon to solve
a problem in real time, and as
the student recited we all
wrote down what the student was
saying in our notebooks.
All the while [? Ms. Dourier, ?]
holding a ruler like a swagger
stick, strode up and down the
aisles, and woe be unto the
poor student who faltered
slightly, let alone get
something wrong.
And that would bring a slap of
the ruler down on the desk and
a sigh of disgust, and
then, all right,
you take it, Audrey.
And then Audrey would begin to
recite until she screwed up
and we would all copy
in our notebooks.
That tyrant so terrorized and
intimidated a bunch of kids in
a redneck, working class
high school that we
really learned algebra.
So to this very day, as a reflex
action, minus b plus or
minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all over 2a.
But I don't have the foggiest
idea how to solve a third
order equation until
I look it up.
You probably never had to do
it, so let me, for your
general education and amusement,
pass around a sheet
that tells you how to solve
a third rank equation.
OK the first step is to convert
an equation in, let's
say, y squared plus y cubed plus
py squared plus qy plus r
equals 0 to a so-called normal
form where you get rid of one
of the terms.
So if you make a substitution
of variables and let y be
replaced by x minus the
coefficient p/3, then you get
an equation that has a
cubic term, linear
term x, and a constant.
And the constants a and b are
combinations of p and q and r
in the original equation.
And then the solutions, not
well known to be sure, are
there's a first solution x is
equal to a plus b, and then,
something messy, x2 and x3 are
minus 1/2 of a plus b plus or
minus an imaginary term--
those are the
second and third roots--
i times the square root of 3
over 2a minus b where A and B
are complicated functions
of a and b.
Capital A and capital B are
functions of little
a and little b.
And then if the coefficients in
the original equation are
real, then you get
one real and two
conjugated imaginary roots.
If this combination of terms
b squared and a squared are
greater than 0, it is b squared
over 4 plus a cubed
over 27 equals 0.
If it's that, then you get
three real roots, two
of which are equal.
In the most general case that we
would be encountering here
is b squared over 4 plus a cubed
over 27 is less than 0,
and then there are three
real unequal roots.
Unfortunately, if b squared over
4 plus a cubed over 27 is
negative that term appears
inside of a square root sign
in the solutions.
So the only case that we'd
really be interested in
doesn't work for the solution.
But fortunately there's another
solution and that's
given at the bottom of the page,
and if you really wanted
to solve a third rank equation
by hand, these solutions would
do it for you.
But I think you'd much prefer
to have your computer solve
the equations for you, but let
me show you a way of doing
this without any computer,
without solving any equations.
And it is a very clever method
of successive approximations
that's based on the properties
of the quadric.
So let's suppose we have a
tensor, and that tensor has
some set of coefficients Aij,
all of which are non-zero.
And I'll assume although this
will work for other quadratic
surfaces that the quadric has
the shape of an ellipsoid.
All right let me now pick some
direction at random, actually
I don't have to pick it at
random, but I'll show you what
the shrewd first
guess would be.
So let's say we picked
this direction.
And let us find the direction
if this is--
let's do it in terms of current
and conductivity.
Let's let this be the first
guess for the applied field.
That's clearly not going to be
one of the principal axes, and
let this be the first resulting
direction of
current flow J1.
So what I'm finding then is a
J sub i in terms of an Aij
times an E sub J, and this is my
first result, and this was
my first assumption.
Let me now let the direction of
J be taken as the direction
of the applied field
for a second guess.
And we could normalize to a unit
vector, but we don't even
have to do that.
So let's simply say that my
second guess for the electric
field that I hope will point
along one principal axis is
E2, and E2 I'll take
as identical--
let's say proportional--
to J1 from my original guess.
So this then would be E2,
the second guess.
And if I find the direction
to the normal--
to the quadric in that
direction, this would be my
second result for the current
flow J, I should have put this
in parentheses to indicate that
these are not components
of E and J.
And you can see what's
happening, look at where I am,
I started out here after just
one iteration I have defined
this as the potential direction
of one of the
principal axes.
So I'm going to find E1--
the direction of the field--
E1 that comes from sigma ij
times Ji, I'll take my second
guess E2 either as identical
to J1 and this is going to
give me then a new value for
my second iteration, this
would be J2.
And this process is going to
converge very, very rapidly on
the shortest principal axis.
As you can see in two shots
I'm pretty close to being
parallel to this direction,
which would be X2 in my
illustration.
Now if I wanted to-- if I wanted
to see if I was close
to convergence--
this is going to be awkward
because if I don't normalize
the magnitude of the resulting
vector, J is going to get
larger and larger and larger.
So periodically I would
want to normalize--
take the magnitude of J,
divide that into the
components, and then I'd
have a unit vector.
If I wrote a computer program
to do this, I would do the
normalization each time
to test convergence.
Now, this is my kind of
procedure, because if I'm
doing this by hand and I screw
up and I make a mistake and my
answer is thrown off a little
bit, if I continue to iterate,
the thing will proceed to
continue to converge to the
shortest principal axis.
So I can make a mistake and it
will correct itself and come
back again, and that's
my kind of solution.
Yeah, Jason?
AUDIENCE: It's going to give you
the minimum value of the
property, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's going to give you the
minimum principal axis, that's
going to be the maximum
value of the property.
So that's one out of three,
hey, that's not bad.
What do I do for the others?
Let me tell you without
proof to find the
maximum principal axis.
And that would be the minimum
value of the property.
What you would do is exactly
the same procedure, and you
would operate on not the tensor,
but on-- using as a
matrix of coefficients--
the matrix of the
tensor inverted.
And I assume you know how to
find the inverse of a matrix,
except that you don't have to
even find the inverse, the
inverse is going to be a
collection of functions of the
original elements divided
by the determinant.
You don't have to worry about
normalizing, all that's
important is the relative value
of these coefficients.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: If your tensor is
symmetric, can't you say that
they'll just [INAUDIBLE]
on to another?
PROFESSOR: That's what
you're going to do.
But when you know just
one, that won't work.
The other two are floating
around somewhere and you don't
know in what direction.
So if you do this, then you have
two out of the three and
now very shrewdly, as you point
out, if we have two of
the principal axes and the
tensor is symmetric, then we
can automatically get the
direction of the third.
If it's not symmetric, then
you have to use the set of
equations, and you have three
principal axes as
eigenvectors, as they're called
in eigenvalue problems.
And they do not have to be
orthogonal, but you have the
components in a Cartesian
coordinate system so you can
find the angle between
those axes.
OK?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: With respect to
whether the matrix is
symmetrical or is
not symmetric,
the quadric is always--
has three principal axes
at right angles right?
PROFESSOR: Only if the
tensor is symmetric.
Only if the tensor
is symmetric.
And let me put your question
aside for about five minutes,
and I want to take an overview
of what we've learned about
the geometry of the quadric and
the symmetry restrictions
that we can impose on the tensor
in a formal fashion,
and see how they compare
and how one allows an
interpretation of the other.
So I'm going to answer your
question, I'd like to wait for
about three minutes.
Other questions?
OK, again this is all very
symbolic, I'm not giving you
an explicit answer,
I can't do it.
But what I can do you--
do for you is, ha
ha, do to you.
I almost slipped and said that,
what I can't do to you,
is give you a problem that
asks you to solve for the
principal axes, for example
of a property tensor.
I will be merciful and perhaps
not have all nine coefficients
non-zero, I will have
one of them zero, or
maybe two of them zero.
So again to try this it is very
instructive and it will
cement what the individual steps
that I performed here
actually involve.
Now, a question that I thought
you were going to ask about
principal axes is that in order
to do what I did here I
am using the radius-normal
property, and the
radius-normal property only
works for a symmetric tensor.
So sounds like I'm swindling
you, except that if I use this
procedure, the radius-normal
won't actually be identically
parallel to the generalized
displacement.
But it's not going to be
terribly different from it,
and I'm going to get something
that again will converge
towards the shortest
principal axis.
And once I'm close to the
principal axis it is true--
symmetric or not--
that the only three directions
before which the generalized
displacement is parallel to
the radius vector are the
principal axes.
But anyway this is a dicey
situation if the tensor is not
symmetric, and it probably comes
as a great relief to
learn that there's really only
one property tensor of second
rank that's known for sure
to be non-symmetric.
So in most cases--
99 out of 100, if not more--
we will be dealing with
property tensors that are
symmetric, so we could use
this procedure.
So again this property converges
remarkably well, and
as I say it has the admirable
quality of being
self-correcting if you make a
mistake, if you're grinding
this out by hand.
But a computer program that
you write that just simply
takes the direction of J,
normalizes it to a unit
vector, applies that as the
generalized force, finds a
quote "J" as a second iteration,
normalizes that,
and then you can check to
whatever degree of convergence
you wish to have in
your solution.
And it's a simple matter to set
up a program to do this.
All right, I think we still have
some time, so let me now
put everything together.
And look at what we've seen of
the geometric properties of
the quadric, and the tensor
arrays that we found for
different symmetries.
For triclinic crystals, for
which the recommended
procedure is to leave by the
nearest exit and work on
something different instead, you
would have nine elements
altogether that are necessary
to define the property.
I'll discuss this in terms
of tensors that
gives you an ellipsoid.
The argument is not different
for hyperboloids of one or two
sheets, and we can't draw
imaginary ellipsoids, but an
ellipsoid is a much easier
thing to draw.
OK, triclinic symmetries, either
one or one bar, nine
elements in the tensor.
No constraints whatsoever on the
shape of the quadric or on
its orientation relative to
our coordinate system.
So, let's total up now looking
at the quadric how many
degrees of freedom there
are in this situation.
We have three principal
axes, so those are
three degrees of freedom.
The orientation of the quadric
is arbitrary, so there are
three orientational degrees
of freedom.
And that comes out to six.
Supposedly nine degrees
of freedom, what
are the other three?
Again, if this is a general
tensor, which is
non-symmetric, the
eigenvectors--
the principal axes that you have
to choose to squeeze this
thing into a diagonal form--
become non-orthogonal.
OK?
So you have another three
degrees of freedom that
specify the mutual directions
of the eigenvectors--
the angles between them.
OK?
The directions in which you have
to pick your coordinate
system, X1, X2, and X3, that
force this thing into a
diagonal form is going to
involve a coordinate system in
which these three angles are not
90 degrees and are fixed
if you're going to squeeze
this thing
into a diagonal form.
And that's it.
So we add these three interaxial
angles in, they're
a total of nine degrees of
freedom for a general non
symmetric tensor.
To convince you that these
interaxial angles for the
eigenvectors really are
variables, let me tell you
something that we may prove
later as a recreational
exercise, or I may give it to
you on a problem set, it's not
difficult to prove.
And that is the result that
a symmetric tensor remains
symmetric for any arbitrary
transformation of axes.
That is from one Cartesian
coordinate system to another.
Now a very salutary effect of
this is that the tensor has
nine elements.
And if the tensor
is symmetric--
if you want to transform
that tensor--
you only have to do the
off-diagonal terms, because
whatever it turns into when
you change the axes, these
off-diagonal terms are going
to be equal to the
off-diagonal terms in
the new tensor.
OK?
So this means that only six--
if the tensor was symmetric in
one coordinate system, only
six elements have to
be transformed.
Actually, it's better than that,
you don't have to do
six, you only have to do five.
And this is the last diagonal
term that can be obtained from
the trace of the tensor.
And that would be the trace of
the tensor T prime after
transformation because A11 prime
plus A22 prime plus A33
prime has to be equal to the
original trace T, which was
A11 plus A22 plus A33 in
the original system.
So if the tensor is symmetric,
you really have to crank
through a transformation for
only five of the nine terms.
Now what is the relevance of
this to what I just said?
If we have the tensor
diagonalized, to a new form
A11, 0, 0, 0, A22 prime, 0,
0, 0, A33 prime, that is a
special case of a symmetric
tensor.
So if you decide to go from
the coordinate system that
produced this diagonalized form
to some other coordinate
system, the new tensor that
you're going to get is going
to be symmetric.
But the thing was not originally
symmetric, so how
can that be?
The answer is you can put it
in diagonal form only in a
non-Cartesian coordinate
system.
And, therefore, that
is evidence that
the reference axes--
the principal axes-- cannot
be orthogonal.
Otherwise you could take the
diagonalized tensor and crank
it back to some arbitrary
Cartesian coordinate, and
suddenly it would go to a
symmetric tensor when it was
not symmetric to begin with.
OK?
QED.
So you can diagonalize a general
tensor only if you
take the axes along the
eigenvectors, which cannot be
orthogonal.
OK, I saw you raise your hand,
I wasn't ignoring you.
That was it?
Good.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to make
sure that Cartesian
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's always nice to
see the class one step ahead
of what you're doing.
All right, let's look at a
couple of more crystal systems
in the form of tensors in those
systems and show that
that in fact does correspond to
the geometric constraints
on the quadric as well.
For monoclinic crystals--
and this is symmetry 2, symmetry
M, and symmetry 2/M.
The form of the tensor when we
took the coordinate system
along symmetry elements
was A11, A12, 0--
terms with a single
three vanished--
A21, A22, 0, 0, 0, A33.
So this was the case where X3
was along the two-fold axis
and or perpendicular to
the mirror point.
OK, number of independent
variables to describe this
property is five.
And if we look at this in terms
of a constraint and
shape in orientation of an
ellipsoidal quadric, says that
one of the principal axes, if
the quadric is to remain
invariant, has to be along
the two-fold axis and or
perpendicular to a plane that
contains the mirror plane, if
a mirror plane is
also present.
So what are the degrees
of freedom here?
This has to be along one
reference axis, x3.
And, indeed, this form of the
tensor occurred only when the
two-fold axes were
parallel, 2 X3.
And this ellipsoid then
was left with
one degree of freedom.
If this is the direction of the
reference axis X2, we have
a degree of freedom in--
shouldn't have called these X1
and X2, these need not be the
coordinate systems.
Looking down on the quadric
along the two-fold axis, the
section of the quadric
perpendicular to the two-fold
axis can have a general shape,
and it can have one degree of
freedom in the orientation of
the principal axis relative to
the coordinate system.
So we have three parameters to
specify the principal axes,
since this is a general
quadric.
We have one degree of freedom in
orientation, and that adds
up to four, but we said five.
So what's going on here?
Again this is a question of
where the eigenvectors point.
If this term is not equal to
this term, in order to force
the tensor into a diagonal
form, you have to pick
eigenvectors in the X1, X2
plane, which will force the
tensor into a symmetric form.
That is, to make this term
equal to this term.
It's only a pair of axes
involved, so there's only one
angle between these two
eigenvectors, which is a variable.
So for a nonsymmetric tensor
plus one angle between the
eigenvectors.
So that comes out, a-ha, five.
And again the way to see that is
I will never get the tensor
into a diagonal form making
all the off-diagonal terms
zero when I'm starting with a
tensor which is not symmetric,
and I know that a symmetric
tensor, even in the special
case where the off-diagonal
terms are zero, is going to go
to a symmetric tensor in another
coordinate system.
So I know that there
has to be an
additional degree of freedom.
OK, the rest come very, very
easily, so let me take just a
couple of minutes to finish up
this stage of the discussion,
and we will shortly go on
to something different.
The next step up in symmetry
is orthorhombic.
And if we pick arc-- and this
could be 222, 2MM or 2/M 2/M
2/M. We found that when we
took X1, X2, and X3 along
two-fold axes that the tensor
took a diagonal form A11, 0,
0, 0, A22, 0, 0, 0, A33.
That says that the quadric
if it's an ellipsoid--
or any other quadratic form--
has all three of its principal
axes along the reference
system X1, X2, X3.
So the only degree of freedoms
here-- and things are again
starting to set up like
supercooled water--
the only degrees of freedom are
the three principal axes.
And that's it, the orientation
is fixed.
And, moreover, the tensor is
diagonal in this reference
system-- it's going to be
symmetric in this reference
system, it's going to remain
symmetric in any other
coordinate system.
So the tensor is always
symmetric, the eigenvectors
then are always orthogonal, even
if the coordinate system
stays Cartesian.
And there are three variables,
three degrees of freedom.
And finally two remaining
cases can
be disposed of quickly.
We saw that for an arbitrary
theta that
is a symmetry element--
so let me not say a symmetry--
for an arbitrary rotation
about X3.
This was the ingenious little
proof in which we transform
the tensor by an arbitrary
rotation theta about X3.
We found that the form of the
tensor was A11, A12, 0, and
now I get to use tensor notation
by calling this term
A12 again and not the proper
indices A21, so I'll put
quotation marks.
"A22" was equal to "A11."
So going to an arbitrary
rotation theta this must be
the form of the tensor we
discovered, and this will
cover then fourfold
axes, three-fold
axes, and sixfold axes.
These two elements are
constrained to have the two
values, these two are
constrained to have the same
values, so the tensor
is always symmetric.
Symmetric relative to these
axes, symmetric in all
coordinates, and any choice of
coordinate system, then.
And that means that if the
quadric has this property,
it's going to have one principal
axis along X3, it's
going to be circular in the
plane that contains X1 and X2,
so there are only, count them
up, there are only three
degrees of freedom.
In terms of tensor elements,
these degrees of
freedom are A1, A12--
in the diagonalized
form-- and A33.
And there are three degrees
of freedom in terms of the
independent elements as well.
So this is for anything that
involves rotational symmetry
other than 180 degrees.
And, finally, for cubic
crystals, if a symmetry
operation other than 180 degrees
gives us this form of
the tensor, two off-diagonal
terms are zero, two diagonal
terms equal.
If we impose this along all
three reference axes, then the
form of the tensor is going to
go to a diagonal form with all
diagonal terms equal.
The quadric that corresponds to
that form is a sphere that
says that there's one quantity,
one degree of
freedom in the form
of the tensor.
There are zero degrees of
orientational degree of freedom.
Thus the spherical quadrics
stay spherical for any
orientation.
So again, one independent
element in the tensor, just
one degree of freedom
in the quadric--
namely its radius--
and, again, the formal
constraints that we obtained
by symmetry transformations
agree with those that are the
same degrees of freedom when
you want the quadric to
coincide with the axes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Speaking of the circle
and the exponents to
play only if A12 equals zero?
PROFESSOR: These two were
equal, but non-zero.
These two are equal, this
one was independent.
And that would be for
the specific case
of a fourfold axis.
Now if we put a fourfold axis
along X1, that's going to
involve these two being
equal and the
non-zero elements become--
let's see--
along X2 it would
be A13 and A23.
No.
OK, we put the four-fold axis
along X2, then this one would
be A22, A11, and A13 would have
to be equal, and 21 and
12 would have to be zero, 23 and
32 would have to be equal.
I think that's the way
it'll go, and these
three have to be zero.
So when you impose all three
constraints, here we've had
these two equal, now we have
these two equal, put the
four-fold access in the next--
in the remaining direction,
and again it has to be
diagonal, and pairwise all of
the off-diagonal terms will be
required to be zero.
AUDIENCE: I mean, when you
diagonalize your matrix the
diagonal term are going to be
all different in this case if
A12 is different from zero.
PROFESSOR: This is not a final
result, this is an
intermediate step.
So we impose this constraint,
plus this constraint, and
that's actually going to give
us all the qualities we're
going to get, but we'd want
to do the same thing for a
four-fold axis along X3.
You put them all together, the
fact that these are zero will
wipe out all of the
off-diagonal
terms, and these things--
for another choice of
axes, these two
would have to be zero.
And for another choice of the
orientation of the four-fold
axis, this and this would
have to be equal.
And, finally, this and this
would have to be equal.
So this is what we found, in
fact, when we cranked through
the symmetry transformations,
and this is what we would get
when we said that the quadric
has to have a shape that
conforms to cubic symmetric.
AUDIENCE: My question was in
the case of the arbitrary
relation of those three.
All three degrees of freedom,
are they, in fact, the three
principal axes?
PROFESSOR: For this case here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: For a symmetric
tensor, they are
two principal axes.
OK?
If the tensor is nonsymmetric,
then these two don't have to
be equal any longer, and
they give you the
extra degree of freedom.
OK?
AUDIENCE: What are the
three degrees of
freedom in this case?
PROFESSOR: I just want
you to know I
appreciate your question.
AUDIENCE: May I make
a suggestion?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think you need two
degrees of freedom to specify
the first one, and since it's
symmetric and since it's
orthogonal you'd only need one
more to find the second one
and then another to
divide the third.
So that's three degrees of
freedom to find three
principal axes in an
orthogonal system.
PROFESSOR: Not sure I like that,
because this has to be
the shape of the quadric for an
arbitrary rotation angle.
AUDIENCE: Does that angle
between X1 and X2-- does it
have to be 90 degrees if
it's not connected?
PROFESSOR: That's correct,
that's correct.
OK, let's not tie up the whole
audience, let me--
let's talk about this and
I'll think about it too.
But you make a very, very good
point, but let's not settle it
in real time.
We'll throw everybody out, we'll
close the door, and you
can come back and see who
won the scuffle, OK?
OK, so let's take our break,
I think you're more
than ready for it.